[Music]
my name is Jeremy Conda and I'm an
engineering manager on the bigquery team
fun fact about bigquery
lots of Google cloud products had big
code names like big store for storage
and big cluster for compute that all
fell by the wayside when those products
launched when it came time to launch
bigquery we consider renaming it but in
the end we decided that there was no
better ways to describe the unique power
of a product than big and query so the
name stuck and the rest is history
[Music]
my name is Jordan sigani and I'm the
director of product man has been for
Google bigquery I was one of the
founding engineers on bigquery ten years
ago now but the most memorable moments
for me was at Google i/o in 2014 where
Felipe Hoffa and I used bigquery on
stage to predict the results of the next
eight World Cup matches in Brazil we
ended up getting all of those
predictions right and yes the US did
lose to Belgium but it was possibly the
most stressful time in my bigquery
career
I'm Daniel Orie I'm a senior engineering
manager on bigquery I'll actually share
my fun fact about dremel so for several
years I was responsible for getting
internal users Googlers to migrate on to
Dremel at that time we got to 85 percent
of Googlers were using it on a monthly
basis and 75 percent on a weekly basis
and I think that that sort of
democratization of data is really the
benefit that a tool like bigquery brings
to organizations
everyone I'm changing law a senior staff
engineer at Google one significant
innovation in bigquery that I'm
particularly proud of this victory and
Mel they created Mel enables users to
easily train and use machine learning
models inside of bigquery just using
sequel we've seen customers be able to
reduce the amount of time and effort it
takes to create a machine learning model
from months to days and I'm chief petty
officer minam I get to be involved in
all areas of bigquery eally
I have the best job if you are getting
started with bigquery you can go with
many different data warehouse designs
you can do classic Kimball schema or
data vault or no sequel types of semi
structured storage really they all will
work very well
the query most how to deal with all of
them so do what makes sense for your
business model
I recommend paying attention to be Chris
Marquis features master Tom ticketed
data model steaming conserves despite
all support ml etc because they can
significantly improve your designs
I'm proud to have been able to
contribute to bring the best of Google's
engineering expertise to the world it's
been an honor to be part of a phenomenal
team of engineers dedicated to bring
that experience beyond the walls of
Google thanks I just want to finish up
by saying thank you to all the bigquery
users and supporters over the years
you've been critical to our success so
far and with your help I think the next
10 years will be as exciting as the last
so big thank you bobbi-claire users